hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today is dev story of capita is always
it's Thursday just to let you guys know
about the schedule for what's happening
with the live streams today was a blog
post next week is going to be an actual
dev stream and then the following week
on September the 26th will be a blog
post the reason that there's going to be
a live stream next week is because of
the new event which we'll get into kind
of thoughts and other speculation and
theories but we have a few other things
to talk about today as you could tell
from the title as long as like the beef
we do enjoy a subscriber for new and
let's get started with today's video so
real quick the game update stuff the
testing grounds is officially over of
phase one they said thank you to all the
warriors who participated in our very
first testing ground the team is now
analyzing the results and then they said
see you on September 19th on the
Warriors then for more details so I'm
obviously like I said last week actually
sorry today the September the 12th I
believe is today that was the ending of
the testing ground so next week on the
19th when they show off the new event
they're probably gonna have a section
dedicated to testing grounds and kind of
give it customer thoughts maybe they'll
give us ideas on what new updates are
gonna bring to the characters maybe
small changes to even you know just to
make the rear works a little bit pepper
as you can see in the background the new
content of the week is signature some of
them look really damn cool obviously if
you want to get those you have as much
time in the world as you want and these
are the new signatures with the names
and what the characters are assigned to
so of course if you do want to grab
those go for right now I'll leave the
video up on screen as usual starting
this week also you can refer your
friends to join for honor on PC and get
some loot it's the four Honor referral
program basically if you have for honor
on PC I will leave a link to this down
in the description if you do want to
check this out for yourself because
there's a lot of Q&A questions but
basically you must have for honor on PC
to do this and all you do is simply log
in to the referral website which is 400
game.com slash referral and then you
have to invite some of your friends from
your Ubisoft friends list and then I
believe if your friends do end up
getting for honor on PC you can get some
rewards
some of those include 5 scavenger crates
5,000 steal 10,000 steal 30 days of
champion status or the very beginning
one is 5 XP boosts and 2 scavenger
crates so you can get all this stuff it
just says reward 1 2 3 4 and 5 I don't
actually know if that means if I get 5
people to join this then that's 30
a champion status for me but it's gonna
be interesting so if you guys do have
for honor on PC and you want to get some
of your friends and want to get some
extra rewards definitely do that and
also you can also use that for me
because you know I need the extra steel
but that's beside the point basically
for a little bit more updates the
referral program ends at November 13th
so you can invite friends up until that
point as soon as November 14th hits you
can no longer do that but if you invite
a friend and he joins after November
14th they have until like a month after
and then you can still get rewards so
just a little recap November 13th is the
last day that you can invite people
December 10th
is the last day that you can get rewards
from the people you invited so there's
that if you want to go do that and
there's like 20 different questions if
you want to know all your different
answers so of course if you totally do
want to do this definitely go check out
the link in the description if this is
for you or if you have a friend that you
want to give him some extra rewards by
hopping onto PC definitely go check this
out regardless and it we have a the
usual Arcade Quest and then we have a
new event challenge which is be the
faction with the most rank to match wins
so definitely do that if you want to get
some extra stuff for your faction other
than that it was passed tournaments and
that's really about it I really want to
talk about the new event honestly I
think this events gonna be cool I'm
always really big on the mythology in
the whole way that they're playing off
with this character being you know with
some Norse mythology some stuff like
that with the urim and Gunder and the
giant sea serpent and the whole lore
behind all of that if you do want to
know a little bit more about the lore of
the character I covered a video which
will be coming up right now on the top
right if you want to click that I
that'll give you a little bit more of
the background of the character what the
name means and stuff like that so it's
actually really cool your man gunner is
actually an occultist of the giant sea
serpent jörmungandr which is how they
got the name that of course is their
actual name that's just the character's
name we think yeah but I have a feeling
we're gonna be getting some nice-looking
mask outfits if we're following a trend
of this year it's most likely going to
be the way that the mask outfits have
been like I think the first season we
got Birds the next one we got those
ghosts in the background whatever we're
gonna get this time I'm it might be new
animals it might be mythic mythological
gods something like that I think it's
gonna be really cool personally I'm not
a big fan of your man gunner myself I
still prefer black prior out of the
entire year of characters but in terms
of the lore and the story Yurman
gundar's definitely got an a-plus for me
so I think this event from a story
perspective is gonna be really sick
obviously they're going to be using
new map which is the breach map of store
strongholds so somehow that's going to
fit into the event game mode obviously
that's really cool because I mean it
means actually people are going to be
playing it because it's a breach map as
for how long that's going to last I
don't know usually with console and PC
as well after like two days people
stopped playing so hopefully people can
all kind of enjoy that yeah let me know
what you guys think about the new event
and what you guys think is gonna be
coming in it I'm assuming that we're
going to be getting new weapons as usual
and the beginning of the season the
developers did talk about releasing new
armor not they never stated when they
just said soon so that could mean next
week for the new event that can mean
next season for the season twelve rule
in character that can be in year four if
that even exists at that point so and we
have no idea
I hope it's next week because I'm always
down for new armor and I know a lot of
you guys in the comments below always
talk to me about wanting a new armor
they did say they're working on it so
regardless we're going to be getting it
it's just if it's gonna be next week
next season next year who knows that
this big guys always like the V if you
do enjoy subscriber for new I come for
the informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening in the world of
foreigner and never miss out or not they
definitely subscribe the channel they
guys so much for the support recently on
the past couple videos as well I know
it's been a little bit hectic with the
monster hundred videos but then guys so
much for watching all the for honor
buddies and can continuing to support me
throughout all these years of the game
and I will gladly keep doing it until
this game is forever gone yeah with that
guys take care have a great yesterday
and I'll see y'all next week and
hopefully we can learn a little bit more
about this new event coming peace out
guys
[Music]
you
[Music]